self-checkout food delivery robots
entirely automated assembly lines robots
have been encroaching on human-led jobs
for decades
but now more autonomous workers are
being welcomed into businesses
than ever before we're giving machines
in general the ability to sense
we're combining those senses with new
and better forms of artificial
intelligence
one of the you know hallmarks of the
coveted crisis
and its aftermath is going to be an
acceleration of the deployment of
all kinds of automation so what does
this mean for the future of the american
worker
at one fedex shipping hub in memphis
tennessee
it means working with robot pickers
fedex
is using these robot arms
combined with an ai vision
and gripping system in order to
one for one replace a human who would
normally be picking up packages from
one place and putting it under a
conveyor belt this
so-called pick step is the single most
common job at e-commerce fulfillment
companies like amazon
and it's been considered one of the
hardest jobs to automate
it's really been the holy grail for
robotics engineers and artificial
intelligence specialists
because it turns out that combination of
our vision and our flexibility and our
dexterity is the one thing that
you really can't replace in a warehouse
but these robots are starting to
encroach on that territory
the effort to reduce human contact at
work has accelerated automation in
other industries as well temperature
checking robots and mask detecting
sensors are policing airports
cleaning bots are sanitizing hospital
rooms and
outbreaks at meat processing plants have
companies racing to develop
robot butchers industrial robots have
been around
since really the late 1950s but they
couldn't see and they couldn't sense
their environment made them very
dangerous
very strong very precise but they had no
adaptability they could only do the same
task
over and over again a lot of the most
spectacular work that's been done in the
past five ten years
has all been in terms of vision systems
when you give robots the ability to see
suddenly if an object is not in the
place that they're expecting it
they can adjust and move and grab it
just like we do
these robots combine hardware like
cameras and sensors with some form of
machine learning software
like the artificial intelligence systems
that allow for partial self-driving
in a tesla and so once you have a system
that is trained
to recognize certain objects or features
of objects
then it can very consistently and very
quickly look at a scene
and in real time say like that's a
person that's a face
that's whose face this is or this is a
package
and this is how i should grab it right
now fedex has four robot pickers
each is half as fast as a human picker
but fedex says they'll become
faster once lessons learned during this
pilot phase are put into practice
human oversight is still needed to help
with sporadic obstacles like a fallen
package
blocking a sensor but fedex says those
snags are rare enough
that one human can simultaneously
oversee eight
robots and because these robots can work
24 7
and they're consistent it's okay that
they're a little bit slower than humans
even so there's good reason shipping
warehouse workers shouldn't feel
threatened by their cobots
just yet demand for home delivery
services
is exploding across the industry ups
says its average daily shipping volume
rose faster this last quarter than
ever fedex says it can't hire fast
enough and is short around 500 human
positions a night
at the same shipping hub that's home to
its robot pickers
amazon has invested heavily in
automation technologies and even buying
companies
that do warehouse automation so
that's clearly front and center it
doesn't
seem like it's winnowing the head count
because there's such a growth in demand
mark murrow has been analyzing the
intersection of regional economies
and technology for decades and while he
agrees that demand is protecting
fulfillment
industry jobs for now he cautions that
similar types of work in other
industries
are not as safe people in routine
non-essential jobs have probably been
laid off
now and probably would be right
to be very concerned about where they
will be hired next
and not just because of workplaces
transformed by social distancing
or robots transformed by sophisticated
ai
but also it's looking like we're on the
brink of a global recession
companies are looking for new processes
and cheaper
ways of delivering goods and services so
they actually
sign up for more automation not less
in downturns just giving a machine the
ability to
not just sense its environment but make
sense
of that information in some way to
identify
where is my goal gives all kinds of
robotics
these abilities to do things that before
were really just the domain of humans
or maybe animals in the last decade
a lot of these technologies became ready
for prime time
and this is prime time now so i do think
we'll see
much more accelerated automation